bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce soir sur arte france quel regard
est ce que vous portez sur ces trois
dernières nuits d'émeutes dans la
banlieue lyonnaise
écoutez c'est de l'inquiétude parce
qu'il ya une véritable un véritable mini
mimétisme qui ce qui se produit à
travers toutes ces opérations que nous
voyons sur vie des villes différentes
on a commencé par la région parisienne
et là on est sur le secteur de lyon
c'est un vrai problème qu'il va falloir
résoudre je pense que la réaction
évidemment viennent contrer je dirais
les travail que fait la police
un terme de ce tube sur ces quartiers
vous savez qu'il ya de gros gros trafic
de stups qui ont lieu sur bon nombre de
ces quartiers et effectivement ça
déstabilise comme on dit le business
donc automatiquement ça ça génère des
troubles et on en voit la preuve encore
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'a affirmé ce
matin gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a expliqué que c'étaient
ses actions de fond de la police contre
un trafic qui motivait les violences
pour vous une guerre est déclarée
aujourd'hui
oui je pense qu'il faut mener une guerre
très très forte sur les réseaux de
trafiquants de succès à cette évidence
avec sa mine de notre société ça me de
notre jeunesse donc il faut réagir très
fortement et en même temps il y avait
autant je m'interroge un petit peu parce
que vous voyez on envoie des beaucoup de
renforts de policiers mais pour pouvoir
je dirais nettoyer ces secteurs là mais
il va falloir qu'à un moment donné on
s'approprie le le terrain de façon
permanente parce que ce renfort de
policiers de gendarmes de crs présents
ne sera que momentanée en attendant que
le climat s'apaise donc il va falloir
travailler sur le fond c'est là où les
problématiques vont se présenter puisque
il ya un plan sur la prévention de la
délinquance qui est mis en oeuvre par le
gouvernement mais il va falloir
l'appliquer de façon intensive et il va
falloir beaucoup beaucoup de gens sur le
terrain pour pouvoir occuper le terrain
et pour éviter toutes ces problématiques
laurent fort de 200 policiers et
gendarmes annoncée par le ministre de
l'intérieur qui est donc arrivé à lyon
il vise à lutter contre les trafics ou
bien faire en sorte que la situation
vécue dans la région lyonnaise ces trois
derniers jours
ne s'envenime écoutez oui c'est pour
apaiser encore une fausse si vous avez
200 gendarmes et crs présents évidemment
dans ces quartiers automatiquement on
apaise de la situation mais ce n'est que
ce n'est qu' un moment je dirais de
limiter puisqu'on va pas pouvoir
détacher en permanence de s'insérer sur
un seul quartier de la région lyonnaise
vous en doutez bien que compte tenu du
nombre de quartiers qui existait en
france donc il va y avoir un travail
encore une fois de forme a mené un
travail de fond sur les stups ça c'est
une chose mais surtout pour assurer je
dirais le service après-vente sociale
dans ces quartiers qui marque c'est à
dire de la présence associative de la
présence de médiateurs d'animateur de
médiateur si on veut avoir des solutions
je pense que c'est une vraie nécessité
alors il y a le le plan de prévention de
la délinquance que le gouvernement mis
en place à en nommant internement
voulant former 300 médiateur et 300
éducateurs spécialisés
ça ne sera pas assez c'est une bon
départ mais ça ne sera pas assez compte
tenu de l'ampleur du travail qui a amené
sur ces quartiers il avait déjà été fait
ou en tout cas promis ce travail ce
travail de fond mais c'est toute la
difficulté va là vous savez travailler
en réaction comme on le fait on est
capable de faire effectivement mais ça
il faut aller sur le fond c'est là toute
la problématique de notre de notre
société on n'est pas capable et les
gouvernements successifs depuis des
années et ce n'est pas seulement le fait
de et la volonté de gérald darmanin non
loin de l'or c'est que le travail de
fond ça demande des effectifs ça devant
notre travail de coopération entre les
élus les élus aussi avoir leur part de
travail là dedans la sécurité et l'autre
je parle d'insécurité c'est cette
fameuse sécurité globale dont on parle
tant avec le travail des polices
municipales qui ont un lien important à
faire en termes de proximité
le travail de la police nationale pour
travailler sur toutes ces problématiques
de trafic de drogue et de stups et voilà
il faut que tu l'ensemble tout le monde
de s'y mettre mais il ya un travail et
sociétal affaire qui est très très long
ça s'appelle le travail éducatif et ça
effectivement les les élus les
politiques n'ont pas ne pas encore la
mesure je pense
les policiers sont mis en cause dans
leur gestion de la situation dans les
quartiers difficiles est ce que vous
diriez qu'il y a
manque de formation des effectifs qui
sont envoyés dans ces quartiers
difficiles
non vous savez c'est ça votre cerveau on
revient toujours au même sujet la
formation des policiers il ya des
policiers d'expérience qui vont
travailler sur ces quartiers
effectivement cantat a envoyé des
policiers des jeunes policiers
effectivement dans des endroits comme ça
pour faire éventuellement des
patrouilles ou tout simplement de la
police de proximité comme on parle je
n'y crois pas un seul instant c'était
possible je pense qu'il ya un vrai
travail de formation mais à travers le
bouddha sécurité la police nationale mr
être intérieur y travaillent assidûment
il ya un vrai travail de remise en
question de la formation de
l'encadrement également qui a besoin de
ceux de se remettre un petit peu en
question et et des moyens des moyens
matériels qui ont ce qu'ils sont déjà
donnés par le ministère l'intérieur
depuis quelques temps déjà mais je crois
qu'il ya encore besoin de beaucoup de
choses mais j'espère que le bouvau de la
sécurité apportera des réponses
concrètes à nos policiers
j'adore merci d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne bruno pomart ex policier du raid
spécialiste des cités